Sei unser Winkelkreis.
Doch, ich war in dem Zelt.
Also so im direkten Vergleich, wenn mein Barfuß drüber lauft.
Ihr könnt ja mal einen Blit-Vergleich organisieren.
Ja, ich bin schon im Kopf dabei.
Lego-Farkir-Contest im Kids-Base.
Apropos Raketen falten, löten, wie auch immer. Ich hab da zwei Sachen dazu. Eine Sache ist, der Rainer, der uns hier nicht nur die Previously macht, der kann auch das mit diesen Raketen. Und der hat Raketen aus Draht gebogen. Der hat dazu auch einen Workshop gemacht und hat mir eine davon geschenkt.
Das ist super cool.
Das ist eine aus dem Design, die anderen waren ein bisschen schwieriger, deswegen sind die nicht gebogen und gelötet worden. Das ist die einfachste von allen, die kann man sich selber biegen. Rainer hat auch die Vorlagen dazu. Die geschwungenen. Die ist schon schick. In meinem Piercing hat sie nicht reingepasst, das haben wir schon aufprobiert. Wollte nicht. Dann hatte Thala eine wunderbare Idee. Ich bin verankert hier bei der Sea-Base. Ich hab mich bei der Sea-Base um die Deko für die Main Hall gekümmert. Ich meinte, Thala, ich hab kein Budget, was kannst du mit Raumschiffen machen? Dann kam sie auf die glorreiche Idee, Raumschiffe in Origami zu falten. Unter anderem auch eine Rakete, die der Herr Pritlove nicht als die Fairy das sehen wollte, sondern als eine Krake. Das hab ich dir gar nicht erzählt, die Beleidigung. Raketen kann man auch wunderbar falten und es gibt ziemlich viele Anleitungen für die ganzen Star Wars. Genau, diese ganzen Sachen als Origami-Geschichten, die man falten kann. Dann hat mir Thala ziemlich viel geholfen bei der Seabase ein SG50-Zelt in Mülltüten zu hüllen, damit es nicht so weiß ist. Und Space Blankets sind oben in der Decke hängen, gefaltete Raumschiffe und Feridus-Raketen. Das hat ziemlich viel Spaß gemacht.
Oh ja, ich hab meine Leidenschaft für Sprühfarbe entdeckt.
Ich hoffe immer noch, dass dieses Zelt heil geblieben ist. Das werden wir dann morgen irgendwann sehen.
Ich bin aber noch am Überlegen, wie ich jetzt meine Tüte mit den ganzen Sprühfarben irgendwie nach Berlin bekomme, in den Öffentlichen.
Ich finde, du solltest auf jeden Fall mit diesen Sprühfarben irgendwie vor dem Ostbahnhof herumlaufen. Die finden das großartig.
Klacker, klacker, klacker.
Was haben sie denn da?
Also ich bin echt froh, dass sich damit in der S-Bahn niemand erwischt hat nach wie vor.
Apropos Seabase, ihr habt ja da auch diesen schönen, die Antenne.
Unseren Fernsehturm.
Der wurde heute noch mal nachdekoriert, was ich sehr, sehr nett fand. Mit einer kleinen Hommage an die Funkstrecke. Da hängt jetzt nämlich auch eine Funkstrecke oben.
Geil.
Das fand ich sehr nettlich.
Das finde ich wirklich toll.
Das Ding ist im Übrigen gar nicht so leicht, hierher zu transportieren, haben wir festgestellt.
Wer hätte es gedacht, oder?
Also der Fernsehturm, den in Berlin abzubauen, ist echt nicht so einfach, ohne dass es jemand merkt. Du hast halt so eine riesige Kugel, die ist gefertigt, ich glaube, innen aus Holz. Und dann verkleidet mit, ich weiß nicht, was alle Schichten sind, unter anderem so Spiegelfolie. Und wenn man die halt versucht anzufassen an der falschen Stelle, macht es knack. Und du hast irgendwie so ein Problem mit dem Skelett, was da drum rumgebaut ist, um die Hülle des Fernsehturms. Und das restliche Holz ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt die leichteste Ladung. Ich hoffe, das Auto war nicht überladen und wir sind nicht vorschriftsmäßig unterwegs gewesen. Aber es ist halt so vom Transportieren her, du hast halt diese riesige Kugel, so ein Transporter ist nicht so groß und man muss die hängen transportieren. Das heißt, wir haben halt versucht, eine Latte zu finden, die man an die Oberkante eines Sprinters hängen konnte, um dann daran diese Kugel zu hängen. Und die wir unten dann aber noch mit so einem, wir haben so eine, was ist das denn, so ein OP-Licht, so ein altes, diese drei Lichter, das haben wir dann auch unten rangeellt, damit diese Kugel nicht die ganze Zeit hin und her meandert in dem Transporter. Also es war sehr spannend, ich bin auch froh, dass sie es überlebt hat.
Also Glück muss sie nicht zurücknehmen.
Theoretisch muss sie nicht zurücknehmen. Die hat ihre Tat, wie heißt das?
In die Entkürbigkeit-Position erreicht.
Ja genau, wir lassen sie einfach in Mildenberg. Das funktioniert ja ganz gut hier mit dem Einlagern, habe ich gehört, mit diesen Öfen. Haben sie nicht hier einen Lehmofen eingelagert?
Ja, stimmt, die haben den Lehmofen aus dem Kids Base eingelagert. Und wieder rausgeholt, und so weit ich weiß auch, wie da ein Betrieb genommen wird.
In einem Ofen eingelagert.
I heard you like Ofens.
Sehr meta.
Ja, das mag ich auch sehr. Was ist denn so euer Eindruck von dem Camp an sich, also in seiner Gesamtheit?
Du hast uns gar nicht dein schönstes Erlebnis erzählt.
Ja, ich grübel noch.
Das war doch seine Makita-Pumpe.
Das war ein persönliches Erlebnis. Wie findet ihr sozusagen die Gesamtkonstellation des Camps? Profimäßig.
Jeder kommt hier, macht so sein Ding, alles geht ratzfatz. Und jeder ist irgendwie beschäftigt und zieht so sein Ding hoch. Also es ist weniger chaotisch als man denkt.
Da kann man nicht meckern.
Wer denkt jetzt? Meist jetzt alle, einschließlich der Teil?
Ja, es sind alle mega vorbereitet. Alle haben irgendwie voll viel dabei, sind ausgestattet hier, glamping. Also jeder hier, gerade Lettini hat schon, also nächste Camp macht Lettie so einen riesen Burg, hat sie erzählt, mit Alm.
Ne Burg?
Nicht. Ach so, ein Village.
Größer auf jeden Fall als jetzt. Und alle denken wahrscheinlich auch so, beim nächsten Mal wird aufgerüstet.
Ja genau, das muss man vielleicht mal dazu sagen. Was ich so bezeichnen fand, war ein Gespräch, was wir in der Business Lounge von Huckel hatten, das nicht mehr so richtig nur noch um Technik geht, sondern alle hierher kommen, um sich wohlzufühlen. Also man bringt die Technik mit, es ist aber weniger geworden, und es ist dieser Komfortfaktor, den alle irgendwie mitschleppen, sei es irgendwie die faltbare Küche oder Küchenschrank, wo ich erst dachte, boah, ganz schön spießig, aber jetzt ist das doch ganz geil. So ein geordeter Küchenschrank, ich bin schon am Überlegen, ob ich ihm gefälscht habe, einen Kleiderschrank nächstes Mal mitlegen. Nur für die Ordnung, also ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber ich finde es irgendwie schön, alles geordnet zu haben.
Den Grund herausfindend, warum sie es geordnet hat.
Als Therapiemaßnahme.
Ja genau, um es ein bisschen so einzunorden.
Let it condo.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall erstaunlich, was die Leute hier so hochziehen für fünf Tage.
Zum Beispiel den Maibaum.
Der Maibaum ist auch wirklich der Wahnsinn. Dieser blinkende oder was auch immer.
Da hab ich schon im Vorbeigehen gehört, versuche den zu enttern oder zu einkassieren. Weil der ist ja wohl aus Bayern oder aus Franken.
Nee, nicht aus Franken. Franken waren es bestimmt.
Also ich meine, das gehört ja dazu.
Ich bliefe an irgendwelchen Leuten vorbei, die gerade Pläne schmiedeten, diesen Maibaum dazu.
Ja ich bin gespannt, wann ich ihn das nächste Mal woanders sehe.
Naja, aber Maibaume muss man klauen, das stimmt schon.
Oh, beim Aufbauen ist er durchgebrochen.
Dann kann man ihn nicht mehr klauen oder was?
Das sah dramatisch aus, aber könnte offenbar wieder gefixt werden.
Sah grad ganz gut aus auf jeden Fall.
Darf ich auch mal was sagen, was jetzt nicht so jubelmäßig ist?
Nein.
Was, Kritik?
Nein, nein. Kritik ist hier nicht erwünscht.
Ich hab ja nur wegen der Funkbuzzlei auch so ein bisschen diese Aufbaunummer miterlebt seit etlichen Wochen. Und die sind auch schon ziemlich cool, muss man sagen. Die haben auch wirklich, da wird auch nochmal sehr viel mehr Zeit dran verbunden. Die Leute, die so seit Anfang, die so seit 5. August hier sind oder davor sogar noch. Und da fiel mir jetzt schon auf, dass je mehr Leute hier sind, desto mehr wird hier dann aber auch verwaltet und verwalten gespielt und Spielregeln aufgestellt und desto mehr Leute laufen auch rum, die dich auf Spielregeln hinweisen und so weiter und so fort. Also es wird sozusagen auch ein bisschen steilverlässig, ein bisschen deutscher. Ich glaube, das muss vielleicht auch so sein, weil je mehr Leute du anschleppst, desto mehr Pappnasen schleppst du auch an. Zwangsläufig. Wobei du hier schon eine ziemlich Pappnasen- und arschlochfreie Zone frisst. Aber es ist mir denn schon aufgefallen, dass sozusagen je mehr Leute hier ankamen, desto mehr Leute liefen hier rum, die sich wichtig machten.
Dieses Bobbycar darf wirklich keine 30-Stunden-Kilometer fahren.
Auch nicht im Kidspace. Ich hoffe, ihr geht bitte nicht auf diesen Turm, wo das Pock drauf stand. Da steht explizit, dass man da nicht draufgehen sollte. Ich hatte schon interessante Diskussionen, dass man müsste doch da raufgehen. Das ist wirklich nicht gestattet. Deswegen hoffe ich, dass es niemals als Anlass nahm, auf diesen Turm draufzusteigen.
Nein, niemand würde das tun. Das finde ich gut.
Alle sind hier sehr verantwortungsbewusst.
Aber natürlich.
Ich dachte ja, ich hätte damit gerechnet, dass das Camp noch ein bisschen mehr selbstversorgermäßig ist tatsächlich. Nachdem das ja auch so in den Ankündigungen schon ein bisschen so durchklang. Ich habe jetzt zwar schon viele Leute mit Solar-Panels, die ihre Powerbanks aufladen gesehen. Und es gibt ja hier und da auch mal so richtige Panels aufgestellt. Aber tatsächlich so beim Rumgehen dachte ich, ich hätte mehr erwartet. Und ja, das ist ein Eindruck.
Jetzt mehr Solartechnik erwartet.
Mehr Eigenversorgung und weniger Material-Schlacht mit so Komfort.
Also mehr Solar, weniger Bredenord.
Ja, was auch immer. Letty hat ja hier in der letzten Sendung mit Wasserfiltern und so angefangen. Und dann haben wir auch ein bisschen Solar und was auch immer besprochen. Aber ja, irgendwie sehe ich halt auch viel von dieser Material-Schlacht und immer mehr und immer größer und noch einen Raclette mitbringen und Waffeleisen und hast du nicht gesehen? Und nach dieser Veranstaltung, wo ihr übers Camp gesprochen habt und diese 100-Sattel-Schlepper, die hier reinfahren und so weiter. Ihr seht ja auch die Stromgeneratoren überall. Also eigentlich fände ich es auf jeden Fall ziemlich geil, wenn man das wirklich noch mehr öko-regenerativ wie auch immer hinkriegen könnte.
Das stimmt, das sind alles Dieselgeneratoren. Das ist mir auch aufgefallen.
Aber ich finde, das zählt ja auch so in dieses Zuhause-Fühlen komfortabel. Nein, nicht komfortabel, aber so dieses Wohlfühlen halt einfach. Du willst halt nicht auf einer Veranstaltung sein, wo es kein gutes Essen gibt. Dann merkt man das sofort, dass alle Leute so ein bisschen so meh, scheiß Essen.
Hast du dir nicht dreimal Pilze aus dem Wald geholt und die haben dann bei uns gegessen?
Der erste war wirklich aus Versehen. Ich bin halt angehalten und am Wegesrand gucke ich so vor, mir ist so, oh ein Birkenpilz, das ist aber schön.
Wann hieß es, dass ich drei Stunden... Ja, die hat vor drei Stunden einen Pilz gefunden. Frag mal, ob sie noch lebt.
Ich nehme nur Pilze mit, die ich kenne. Und gestern war ich mit einer Freundin hier noch irgendwie Pilze jagen und da haben wir auch nochmal eine gute Mahlzeit gefunden. Na ja, so durch den Wald. Pilze sind Rudeltiere.
Du meinst du hast den ersten gegessen und die zweiten sind schon weggelaufen?
Nein, das waren wirklich nur Birkenpilze. Aber es war nicht so eine kluge Idee, irgendwie mit den Flip-Flops und kurzen Hosen in diesen Wald reinzurennen. Ich hab irgendwie so einen Stachel im Oberschenkel am Ende gehabt. Ja, ich hab auch direkt so Tala so. Sieht das noch gut aus?
Wenn's schlimmer wird, zum Zert kommen.
Kurze Frage zwischendurch, hat jemand ein Taschentuch? Ich als Heuschnupfer und Staubfreund.
Wo wir schon gerade bei der Erteilung sind, was fehlt? Vielleicht hat hier noch jemand einen Tipp für mich? Ich suche mal eine Gelegenheit, wo man mal einen Schokoriegel erwerben kann.
Ich hätte hier so...
Also es gibt ja super geile Karamell-Brownies, aber ich weiß nicht.
Ich hab dir hier noch welche mitgebracht.
Müsli-Schoko?
Ja, nee, so rege ist viel zu gesund. Ich meine so richtig ordinäre, so was.
Du kriegst nach der Sendung noch einen.
Sehr gut, alles klar.
Ich weiß, dass heute irgendwann...
Und die Gelddrucker. Zum Er-Autonomie bitte nächstes Mal mehr Gelddrucker mitbringen.
Gelddrucker?
Naja, so diese Dinger, die man bedroht mit Plastik und dann drucken die Geld.
Das wäre tatsächlich praktisch.
Stimmt, das gibt es gar nicht so lange.
Gibt es irgendeine Bank, die sich finden würde, die hier einen Geldautomaten hinstellt?
Das ist Berlin Only, oder was?
Und ich hätte da noch eine Anmerkung zum Grauwasser-Thema. So ein paar Urinade wären nicht verkehrt. Dann würden die Leute, die sich einfach wirklich nicht hinsetzen, vielleicht irgendwo hinstellen, wo es okay ist, weil kein anderer sich da hinsetzt.
Ich fühle das nicht weiter aus.
Aber glaub mir, es wäre besser.
Ich finde ja, man könnte in solchen Hygiene betreffenden Verhaltensweisen dann auch nochmal auf selbige einwirken.
Könnte man, hilft aber vielleicht nicht. Ganz so gut wie die andere Lösung.
Was mir so ein bisschen fehlt, sind die Kompoletten von dem Fusion-Griddle. Die finde ich ja so großartig, die stinkten auch nicht. Wobei, hier gibt es zum Glück keine Dixie-Klos. Als Frau ist es immer so ein bisschen so ein...
Doch, hier gibt es Daten-Klos. Du weißt auch, was mit denen passiert ist.
Ja, sie wurden viermal schon benutzt, weil sich jemand...
Aber hinterher korrekt, wir werden mit Kabelbindern geschlossen.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, ob das gut oder schlecht ist. Aber ich mein, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber als Frau finde ich immer so, dass so eine Veranstaltung steht und fällt mit der Hygiene.
Anstrengend. Für die Oberschenkel vor allem.
Entschuldigung, das verstehen nur die wenigsten. Hallo Frauen. Das fand ich auch in der Fusion irgendwie so interessant an dem Gelände, dass sie sich diese Kompoletten gebaut haben und du hast so dieses...
Das ist jetzt aber keine Gesichtsbehaarung, oder? Ach nichts.
Das sind Kompost-Toiletten.
Genau, Kompost-Toiletten, die mit Säge spielen und ab und zu, glaube ich, auch mit einer Schicht Erde versehen werden, in der du halt dein Geschäft verrichtest. Und was interessant ist, wenn es warm ist, stinkt es nicht. Und ich fand das immer irgendwie total toll. Ich weiß nicht, wie nachhaltig das ist.
Ich wollte auch gerade fragen, wieso weißt du, wie warm es ist.
Wie warm es ist? Ja, wenn es draußen warm ist.
Ich kann dir sagen, warum es nicht stimmt, weil diese Kompoletten Urin und Scheiße trennen.
Ja, aber ich fand, ich würde mich gerne, da könnte es im Übrigen mal ein CRE drüber machen.
Genau, genau.
Tim macht ein CRE. Über die Kompoletten, ob das nachhaltig ist und wie das funktioniert. Ich fand das interessant, dieses Prinzip zu sehen. Kackst da schön in diese Tonne rein oder pinkelst da rein, das ist ja auch egal. Aber ich fand das interessant, weil es im Vergleich zu anderen Festivals, wo du diese Dixie-Hölle hast, also nicht als Datenklot, Clemens, fand ich das echt interessant. Kannst du das mal machen?
Und wer trennt das, Tim?
Wie läuft die Trennung ab?
Wie wird es getrennt, wer trennt das?
Die Schwerkraft? Ich hab gesehen, dass da auch ein Rohrsystem war. Ich vermute, dass sie damit...
Das rupft sozusagen raus, also die Flüssigkeit läuft dann raus. Da sind so Gitter, genau, und dadurch wird das halt getrennt. Und die ganze Urin wird dann halt gleich da, wo auch die anderen Pissoirs alle hin abgeleitet werden, wird das sozusagen gleich weggeschickt. Aber was stinkt, ist immer der Urin. Die Scheiße stinkt eigentlich gar nicht, was ganz lustig ist eigentlich auch. Man denkt ja, die Scheiße stinkt, aber die Scheiße stinkt nicht.
Aber da konntest du mal ein CAA drüber machen. Das fand ich etwas sehr schreckt, Egan. Drüber.
Damit hast du die komplette Nahrungskette einmal abgearbeitet.
Ich bin mittlerweile so in dem Alter angekommen, wo ich sogar fünf Tage camp als zu kurz ansehe. Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber es ist schon alles in so einem Equilibrium angekommen.
Das sind schon fünf Tage.
Du volontierst für den Abbau, höre ich gerade.
Ja, ich weiß, dass das alles Herausforderungen sind, gerade was so Helfer und auch bestimmte Kosten betrifft, die sich auch mit jedem Veranstaltungstag verlängern. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist irgendwie so dieses Mittwoch Anfang irgendwie auch nichts.
Du warst da schon vorher hier.
Das sind ja auch sehr viele.
Ja, ich wäre auch sonst vorher da. Dann wäre ich halt zwei Wochen hier. Das ist auch sehr schön. Oder drei?
Genau, die letzten drei Tage sind Talks.
Das ist doch okay. Ich finde schon, es ist schon ein Unterschied, ob du den Operations-Modus auch wirklich angeworfen hast oder ob du nur sozusagen darauf hinfieberst. Dieses Ein-Par-Tage-Vorher-Kommen finde ich einfach wichtig, um überhaupt erst mal ein bisschen runterzukommen und sich ein bisschen darauf einzustellen auf den ganzen Modus. Aber ich denke, es müsste eigentlich immer so weitergehen.
Die Dusche habe ich auch nicht an Tag 0 oder 1 gefunden. Es dauert, bis man hier alles mal gesehen hat.
Die Zertschichten helfen.
Genau, da wüsste ich noch ganz gerne, wer dieser Troll war, der das Zelt Johnson auf die eine Seite und das Hackcenter auf die andere Seite gepackt hat. Aber dann stand es im Plan genau andersrum. Wer war das? Zahlreiche Verabredungen sind gescheitert, weil ich den Leuten immer gesagt habe, sie sollen sich zum Zelt Johnson bewegen und Johnson war dann überhaupt gar nicht da.
Bitte melde dich.
Hat Johnson auch eine Decktnummer auf dem Rücken geklebt?
Aber das ist irgendwie der einzige Fehler, den ich so richtig erkennen kann an dieser Veranstaltung. Deine Karte ist einfach nicht up to date. Was?
Deine Karte ist einfach nicht up to date.
Das ist die Karte, die wir alle in die Hand bekommen haben.
Echt? Print oder was?
Ja.
Ach so.
Ich dachte, Print ist tot.
Ja, merkbar.
Deswegen.
Alles falsch. So, haben wir noch Themen?
Wir könnten ja noch mal auf diese Cardio zurückkommen.
Ich hab noch ein Request kurz. Ich bin hier nebenan, muss noch so ein Display reparieren und ich brauch einen... Artmeld Dragon, wenn's geht, wenn einer so was hat, kann er sich an mich wenden.
Was mit Cardio?
Ich finde, dass dieses Mal das Cardio einfacher zu bedienen ist, als vorher die Radio-Batch und vor allem auch das Zusammenfrickeln wesentlich einfacher geht, außer man verliert die Schrauben. Aber es ist wirklich nur einmal draufkleben, paar Schrauben zusammen, fertig, du hast deine Batch. Ich finde es sehr schön, keine Ahnung, wie gut diese Sensoren für das Cardio funktionieren, aber es blinkt erst mal ganz schön am Arm. Man sollte damit nicht auf Toilette gehen oder Händewaschen ist vielleicht auch schwierig, ein bisschen hochziehen. Ich weiß nicht, wie gut das mit dem Wasser sich verträgt, aber... Aber mit schon duschen, auch schön, ja. Vielleicht kann man damit auch duschen.
Ja, und lebt die Cardio noch? Nein, ja super. Merkst du selber, oder?
Einmal.
Genau, ein einziges Mal.
Ich hab übrigens heute erst entdeckt, oder gestern Abend, oder durch Zufall, durch einen Tweet der Firma Bosch, wir sagen jetzt nur den Namen, um das Vok zu dissen, dass da ein Luftgütesensor mit drauf ist.
Luftgüte?
Ja, da hab ich noch keine Abführ gefunden.
Ja, doch, man kann so Temperatur sehen, Hektopascal und irgendeine Einheit-Lukumkante.
Nee, das Ding soll Gas schnüffeln können. Es soll gefährliche Gase schnüffeln können.
Vielleicht war das das.
Und das erzählt dir die Firma Bosch.
Hör auf meinen Staub.
Es sind immer noch 27°C.
Aber da gibt es noch keine Abgase.
Irgendjemand anderes meint, das ist die zweite Zeit.
Ihr müsst das wiederholen. Dieselabgase lassen sich damit nicht schnüffeln, habe ich verstanden. Stimmt das?
Das ist ja auch von Bosch oder nicht?
Wer, der da?
Bei der Sensor wahrscheinlich, oder?
Meine ist gerade die Batterie verstorben hier in der Sendung. Hat jemand den USB-Lader da?
Denne sicher hat sein Kabel nur so zu impfen.
Aber ich hab's ja hier.
Jetzt wird erstmal die Makita Powerbank an die Uhr angeschlossen.
Die Idee finde ich ganz interessant, über Micro-Python an das Gerät heranzugehen. Beim IMF-Camp auf dieser Tilder-Batch gab es das ja auch schon. Das ist auf jeden Fall erstmal eine Hürde weniger, als mit C herumzuarbeiten. Wenn man das nicht kennt und Python ist, finde ich schon nochmal eine gängigere Sprache oder eine einfache Sprache.
Python ist die Hürde.
Wollen wir noch über Tabs und Spaces reden? Da wären wir nie fertig. Ich fand das irgendwie schön und ich hab jetzt auch nichts Besonderes gemacht, außer mal so irgendwie den... so einen Regenbogen über das HSV. Das hattest du mir ja mal empfohlen, nicht über RGB einen Regenbogen lupen zu lassen, sondern über diese HSV-Farbskala. Und irgendwie läuft da jetzt halt fast ein Regenbogen über meine Uhr. Mit einem Offset natürlich, damit nicht jede dieselbe Farbe hat. Das ist sehr schön.
Nicht über St. Pauli? Ein Fußballwitz muss sein, oder?
Hey, dass Tim noch nichts über Fußball geredet hat. Ehe so, warst du nicht am Sonntag bei Union?
Soll ich jetzt da was zu erzählen?
Nee, das wollen wir nicht.
Das war auch nicht so glorios, oder?
Sprich das doch nicht an, doch, das war extrem glorios.
Ich hab's dir nicht gesagt, guck Roddy an.
Diese LSD-Farbmodi sind auch echt...
Kommen wir zu den Anwendungen. Ich kritisiere ja immer die Anwendung. Und ich find das ja ganz toll, dass wir so Hardware-Plattformen haben, die dann alles Mögliche theoretisch ermöglichen können. Man könnte ja, ein Sensor hier und ein Sensor da. Aber frage mich halt immer noch, ob nicht für ein Device nicht primär auf das Event hin ausgerichtet sein sollte.
Da sind Raketen drauf. Ja, in blau, in gelb und grün.
Jedes Mal, wenn du an Dingen vorbeiläufst, kannst du dir dann ein EKG machen oder deine Herzfrequenz anschauen und sagen so das berührt mich so sehr gerade, dieses Licht da im Baum.
Kannst du das dann auch per Bluetooth an dein Telefon schicken und das dann per Instagram mit deinen Freunden sharen?
Die Leute, die gestern dieses Schüttelspiel gespielt haben, fand ich aber auch sehr lustig anzuschauen.
Du willst dir das vom Thema ablenken oder was?
Nee, da gibt es so ein Spiel, wo er misst, wie stark du die Hand bewegst. Wenn du sie zu stark bewegst, dann geht dein Licht von grün auf rot und dann bist du draußen. Und der letzte, der noch irgendwie eine grüne Uhr hat, der gewinnt dann. Und dann rennen die da wie die Bekloppten rum.
Ja, ist das korrekt? Ja, das ist auch nicht neu, das gab es schon, ich weiß nicht, das gab es schon vor länger, ich weiß nicht, schon eine ganze Weile unterwegs. Ja, das ist an sich ein ganz gutes Beispiel, wie ich finde, weil es nämlich tatsächlich für die Dynamik auf der Veranstaltung enorm was beiträgt. Also wenn du so acht Leuten zuschaust, die dieses Spiel spielen, also für die Leute, die es noch nicht verstanden haben oder nicht gesehen haben, das ist so ein bisschen, als wenn du so ein Waffeleis in der Hand hast, quasi aber als Gerät, wo dann die Eiskugel leuchtet, also im Prinzip ein bisschen digitaler Eierlauf. Und die Kugel signalisiert halt mit ihrer Farbe ihren Zustand und wenn sie halt noch nicht genug geschüttelt ist, dann hat sie irgendeine Farbe und wenn man es halt so schnell macht, dann wird sie rot und dann ist man raus. Und da halt acht oder zehn Leute gleichzeitig irgendwie so einen Teil in die Hand gedrückt bekommen, wabern sie jetzt alle wirklich so wie so Eurythmisten aus der Waldorfschule umeinander herum und versuchen die anderen in so eine Situation zu bringen, in der sie sich zu viel bewegen, ohne dabei natürlich sich selbst zu viel zu bewegen. Und das erzeugt tatsächlich interessante Muster. Ich hab mir das an diesem wunderschönen Bus, der hier irgendwo steht, habt ihr den gesehen? Dieser Bus, der oben noch mal so einen Balkon oben drauf hat, ist auch großartig. Also ein Bus, wo so quasi eine Holzdecke oben drauf ist. Ja, du kannst einfach in den Bus rein und dann stehst du irgendwie da oben, wirst auch mit Getränk begrüßt und so weiter und kannst dich da über Künstliche Intelligenz unterhalten. Und man kann vor allem halt von oben schauen. Da sah ich dann auch gerade mal wieder so eine Bande dieses Spielspiel. Und ich fand das einfach so von der ganzen Raume-Ästhetik erstmal ganz nett, weil du hast natürlich im Dunkeln diese leuchtenden Eier, die dann sozusagen die ganze Zeit umeinander kreisen. Aber es ist natürlich auch so von dieser ganzen physischen Interaktion, die Menschen so miteinander haben, auch ein schönes Bild. Wir wissen ja also, dass der gemeine Nerd gemeinhin ja sozusagen Bewegungsprobleme hat. Und auch was die soziale Interaktion betrifft, alles noch so ein bisschen verbessernfähig ist. Solche Sachen natürlich ganz gut. Wenn wir das dann wieder zurück übertragen auf die Idee eines Badge im Sinne von etwas, was jeder bekommt und jeder trägt, würde man sich da nicht wünschen, auch etwas als Anwendung auf so einem Gerät zu haben, was genau solche Effekte auch befeuert.
Es ist schon staubig genug auf dem Camp.
Außerdem kannst du dir sagen, ob du angesprochen werden möchtest oder nicht.
Exakt, ganz wichtiges Video.
Ja, grün und rot. Aber hast du gesehen, wie viele Leute mit blinkenden LEDs durch die Gegend rennen? Ich meine, da weißt du ja überhaupt nicht mehr, was das bedeutet. Du bist rot und grün gleichzeitig. Machst mich ganz muschig.
Wo ist deine Uhr? Hier. Nein, die andere. Die richtige.
Ja, ich hab das noch nicht. Ich meine, EKG hab ich schon seit ein paar Jahren.
Mir wurde vorhin gesagt, dass es möglich ist, per Bluetooth-LE den Buzzer einzuschalten. Das hat Toto rausgefunden. Da ist ja so ein kleiner Vibrationsmotor drinnen, und den kann man per Bluetooth-LE einschalten, auch ohne Authentifizierung. Und dann kann man für jeden, der im Umkreis ist und BLE eingeschaltet hat, kann man... Genau!
Ja, aber das ist in der Tat schon mal ein ganz guter Ansatz. Also ich meine, man könnte ja im Prinzip so einen Hidden Tinder einbauen.
Tinder als App gab es schon.
Auf dem Kardio? Und wie funktioniert die?
Untergeladen.
Ach so.
Rainbow Improved war drüber und das muss ich nehmen.
Naja, wenn dann sozusagen deine potenziellen Partner in Crime in deiner Nähe sind, dann fängt es halt so an zu vibrieren. Und dann musst du um dich herum schauen, wer von denen so aussieht, als würdest du auch gerade vibrieren.
Das läuft im normalen Leben genauso.
Ja, genau, das ist quasi so ein Emotionsverstärker. Vielleicht kann man ja auch mit diesem Herz... Was ist das noch? Also, aber man muss ja da sozusagen nochmal ein spezielles Kabel ranmachen und sich dann wirklich diese Kontakte irgendwo drauf machen.
Nee, du hast keinen Sensor, machst einfach deinen Daumen drauf.
Die Kabel sind extra.
Ach, die Kabel sind extra?
Musst du nicht benutzen.
Ein Kanal, EKG, also.
Okay, na super, und können wir da auch so Emotionen, also so Anwallungen?
Pulsrate kriegst du auf jeden Fall hin. Und Aussetzer vom Herzschlag.
Dann ist eh schon.
Dann sind da die, die nicht zusammen passen vielleicht.
Ja, vielleicht.
Das ergibt das natürlich auch.
Die Linie ist recht flach.
Also wär dein sozusagen Puls-Sensor nicht viel sinnvoller?
Ist es ja quasi.
Weil wenn du EKG-Ausschläge hast, dann siehst du gleichzeitig auch deinen Puls.
Dein Herz schlägt verkehrt rum.
Ich glaube, ich hab Herzprobleme.
Wollen wir zum Zert gehen? Wir haben coolen EKG, auch mit mehr als eine Kanal-Ableitung. Sogar zum Ausdrucken.
Was möchtet ihr den Menschen hier noch mit auf den Weg geben heute?
Alles Liebe.
Geht auf fehlkauf.bilt, liked, retweeted, shared.
Was ich jetzt meine, wir haben jetzt noch einen Tag Zeit. Dinge, die ihr hier gesehen habt, von denen ihr möchtet, dass man sie unbedingt gesehen hat.
Auf dem Berg hab ich beim Aufbau gesehen. Danach hab ich es aber nicht mehr hingeschafft. Jungs, die eine steuerbare Antenne haben, die die Wetter-Satelliten verfolgen und deren Daten abgreifen. Und?
Werden die Daten nicht sowieso bereitgestellt?
Genau, selber machen.
Ah, den Downlink.
Außer im drehen Antennen sind doch cool. Nicht?
Du bist so ein einfaches Gebiet.
Ja, mehr Sachen mit Holz und kleinen Antennen.
Ich finde, man soll sich hier verlieren. Einfach mal wirklich rumlaufen und mal wissen, wo man nicht mehr ist, wenn man so geflasht ist von den Eindrücken, die hier so sind, von den Lichtern. Ich hab ein paar Sachen entdeckt, die auf dem Kongress, glaube ich, auch standen. Irgendwo ganz woanders, weil ich von oben drauf geschaut hab. Nur dann hab ich es überhaupt erst gesehen, diese Strukturpalme. Die stand bei Saal 2 irgendwie in dem Raum, ich weiß immer nicht, wie die ganzen Sachen heißen, in irgendeiner Halle. Die hab ich irgendwie so von oben herauf, schön beleuchtet gesehen.
Bitte?
Chaos West, genau, stimmt.
Eine Strukturpalme?
Ja, so eine Palme.
Steht neben der Rakete.
Ein Stück weiter davor, ja.
Egal, je nachdem aus welcher Richtung du guckst.
Wenn man von oben guckt, steht sie davor.
Was ist denn eine Strukturpalme? Du hast es gesagt, also ich frage ja noch.
Eine Palme aus Struktur.
Struktur, genau. Nicht aus Blättern.
Nicht aus Blättern.
Keine Blätterpalme, sondern eine Strukturpalme. Ich finde das so offensichtlich.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, was Sache ist.
Wenn du sie siehst, wirst du dich daran erinnern und dann siehst du, das ist eine Strukturpalme.
Einfach nach einer Palme-Ausschau halten, Tim, und dann ist alles gut. Oder nach so einer Tiki-Body aufhören.
Und wenn die ordentlich Struktur hat, dann ist es eine Struktur-Palme.
Die Tiki-Bar ist ja hier so ein Import aus Seattle.
Kennen die alle nicht.
Wer kennt was nicht?
Die Tiki-Bar. Von früher meinst du diese Video-Serie?
Nein, ich meine nicht diese Video-Serie.
Die Video-Serie, die du machst, an die ich natürlich auch zuerst denken musste, als ich das gehört habe, ist ja sozusagen nur spielt in einer Tiki-Bar. Aber Tiki-Bar ist an sich ja ein Konzept. Und Tiki-Bar ist halt im Wesentlichen Hawaiianische Cocktails in den passenden Dings anbieten. Und die haben sich den Spaß gemacht, halt nicht nur eine Tiki-Bar hier mit irgendwie aufs Camp zu schleppen, sondern sich jeden Tag woanders hinzustellen. Das ist ganz lustig. Mobile Tiki-Bar. Ja genau, also ich kann euch nicht sagen, wo ihr hingehen müsst, aber es gibt irgendwo eine Tiki-Bar, die man finden kann und dann gibts da Drinks.
Und Hawaii-Shirts. Die haben auch eine Garderobe.
Und Hawaii-Shirts. Und man darf die auch mitnehmen.
Muss man das Shirt anziehen, um einen Drink zu kriegen?
Man kann das tun, aber ich glaube, es ist nicht Pflicht.
Wir sind doch auf dem Camp. Aber die besten Sachen findet man auf jeden Fall sowieso, wenn man nach ganz anderen Sachen sucht. Also das zu diesem Mal gehen, laufen lassen und so. Ich hab auf jeden Fall auch mir immer jeden Tag eine Mission gestellt, was ich finden müsste. Und hab dabei ganz viele andere tolle Sachen gefunden. Zum Beispiel die Eiswürfelmaschine hab ich gleich an Tag Null gefunden. Das haben ganz viele andere gesucht, verzweifelt und ich hab die schon gefunden.
Wir sind einfach hingegangen.
Aber es gibt Leute, die haben sie bis heute noch nicht gesehen.
Aber dabei zeigen überall Schilder in Richtung.
Ja, aber mit diesen ganzen Wegen und bei Nacht. Also ich hab gestern mich auch nochmal verlaufen, tatsächlich auf dem Camp.
Die steht hier in unserer Wegkreuzung, ne?
Genau, auf der.
Direkt neben einem Dreh den Ort, man kann's gar nicht verfehlen.
Der kleine Huckel möchte vom Zert abgeholt werden.
Hast du die Decke hinten drauf?
Ich hab's nicht geschafft, auf so einer Bahn mitzufahren. Das hätt ich gerne gemacht.
Die fahren auch selten, da hab ich den Eindruck.
Eine Bahn oder eine selbstgebaute Bahn?
Irgendeine Bahn, egal was.
Da ist ein Fahrplan, da steht.
Ich bin einfach bei einer zugestiegen, die vorbeikam.
Manchmal fahren sie und manchmal nicht.
Ja, die haben nicht... Also dann hätte sie mich überfahren fürchtig.
Also nicht von den fahrenden Bahnen runterspringen. Vor allem, wenn man normalerweise sitzender Informatiker ist.
Im Haus beruflich.
Verdrehte Knie und verstauchte Knöchel sind Hochkonjunktur.
Die Bewegungsexpertin hat gesprochen.
Ist generell so ein bisschen unpraktisch von schneller fahrenden Objekten.
Reden wir von der gleichen Bahn? Schneller fahrende Objekte?
Die sind teilweise ganz schön. Man unterschätzt es auch, wenn man drauf steht und denkt, die ist langsam genug, dass ich springen kann, aber eigentlich nicht in der Lage bin zu springen und schon gar nicht sinnvoll zu landen.
Apropos Haltestellen, die aufploppen beim Pilze sammeln. Nein, wir waren nüchtern. Wir sind irgendwo reingekommen und da gab es so eine Gartensiedlung und auf einmal stand da so eine Abfahrtsplan von einer BVG, weiß ich nicht, irgendwas Mildenberg nach, keine Ahnung, wirklich so im Nichts vor so einem einzelnen Häuschen, so ein alter, ich glaube, es ist ein alter BVG-Fahrplan. Wir standen da so, okay, mit Busabfahrtzeiten. Also hier wird man nicht nur auf dem Camp getrollt, sondern auch ein bisschen außerhalb.
Ich hab ja hier meinen Landsitz in der Nähe und ich kann dir sagen, dass bis vor gar nicht allzu langer Zeit fuhr der Bus bei uns Donnerstags.
Das Ding ist, wenn man den verpasst, braucht man ein bisschen. Da gab es keine richtige Straße, also jedenfalls keine befestigtes Gartenwaldweg.
Ist das vielleicht so für Seniorenheime, wo die Leute, es gibt es wohl wirklich, dass in Seniorenheime für demente Leute Haltestellen aufgebaut werden, damit sie...
Nicht mehr wissen, dass sie gar nicht mehr in Berlin sind.
Nee, da gehen die da hin und warten auf den Bus, wenn sie wegrennen wollen.
Demente Leute müssen meistens immer gerne öffnen, wenn sie irgendwo hin sind. Das ist so ein Krankheitsbild, dass sie das Gefühl haben, irgendwo hin zu müssen. Aber sie sind da nicht so crazy, dass sie dann losjoggen, sondern sie setzen sich halt hin und warten auf den Bus. Und abends werden die da wieder einkassiert. Und da kommen halt nur die Pflegergelenklich mal vorbei.
Mit dem Bus hoffe ich dann.
Ich hab das in einem Altenheim auch wirklich mal gesehen. Das war an die Wand gemalt, eine Bushaltestelle, aber da war niemand da.
Ich hab ja eine Geschichte gehört, dass Leute im Floß oder am Boot anreisen wollten, aber dann die Schleuse einen Defekt hatte. Das Floß oder das Boot zurückbleiben musste und dann ein Nerd mit 37 Kilometer mit Rucksack irgendwie zum Camp alleine dann aufgebrochen ist und die anderen zurück an der Schleuse gelassen hat.
Nach dem Fußmarsch ist da doch kein Nerd mehr.
Fand ich auch ganz putzig.
Ich find's sehr lustig am Kidspace. Ich neige auch dazu, wenn ich ins Wasser gehe, mich sehr, sehr dumm anzustellen und mich nicht reinzutrauen. Die einfachste Technik ist ja, einfach reinzuspringen. Aber hier ist das regelrecht so ein Fließband an...
An Nisstrauern.
An sehr, sehr blassen Männern, die sich nicht ins Wasser reintrauen und dann alle so Zentimeter für Zentimeter gehen.
Ich habe Farbe bekommen.
Aber wirklich auf der Hand.
Wann machst du das letzte Mal duschen? Es gibt ganz oft diesen Effekt. Ich habe Farbe. Nein, das ist Dreck. Du musst mal wieder duschen.
Das ist tatsächlich was, was ich auch... Also jetzt nicht unbedingt sehenswert, eher nicht sehenswert. Trinkt genug und wascht euch regelmäßig Hände und Füße.
Ich meine, du läufst zur Dusche, hast die saubersten Füße dort, musst 20 Minuten zurücklaufen. Die sind schmutziger als zuvor. Also es ist unmöglich hier staub...
Ja, da gibt's...
An sich ja.
Ich kann aber sagen, diese Füße wurden nicht geduscht. Wurden nicht sauber gemacht.
Da gibt's ein Life Hack, fahr mit dem Fahrrad. Dann musst du nicht in dem Dreck rumrennen. Fahrrad.
Immerstiefel.
So ein Fahrrad.
So ein Fahrrad ist super.
Ja, hab ich doch gleich am Anfang erzählt.
Ja, aber noch hier.
Von Tim Habe.
Echt?
Dir schreibt ein Hafen?
Mir hat der Hafen geschrieben, ja.
Aber was ganz Persönliches und Privates.
So, wenn es auch eine schöne ginge. Wer da noch nicht war, ist ein bisschen oft noch mal von hier, aber da hinten gibt es noch so einen Hafen.
Das ist auch meine Mittagsstelle.
Ich finde ja diese Chaos Post wirklich ein ganz hervorragendes Ding, weil man wirklich auch zu... Diese Möglichkeit, irgendwie Leute zu erreichen, von denen man noch nicht mal weiß, wer sie sind. Das ist toll.
Kennt ihr eigentlich das TOC, das Turtle Operations Center? Unsere Schildkröte vom Zert hat tatsächlich Post bekommen und sie hängt ganz...
Wieso hat denn das Zert eine Schildkröte?
Zur Beruhigung. Hinter dem Zelt haben wir sogar mit Livestream inzwischen... Zert Twitter, da ist der Link drauf. Und man kann der Schildkröte zugucken.
Das ist das Turtle Operations Center.
Ja, das ist das TOC.
C3 TOC. Ich hoffe, es kommen keine Westmanns.
Nein, C3 TOC ist Troll Operations. Rupert heißt er.
Rupert hat Post bekommen. Und das ist tatsächlich auch das Naste, wie ich an die Post Engel rangekommen bin.
Oh, da beugt sich gerade jemand über Rupert.
Ich hoffe, er landet nicht in der Suppe.
Also wenn wir hier mal den zweiten Screen nochmal aufmachen können, dann können wir uns mal Rupert kurz anschauen.
Das endet in einem Desaster.
Da brauchen wir ja keinen Ton.
Rupert liegs.
So, und das soll jetzt live sein?
Bist du aber sicher, dass dieser Mensch im Bild da auch zu gestimmt hat?
Klaut der die gerade oder was macht der mit dir?
Aber es strömt hier auch nicht wirklich. Wahrscheinlich geht das wieder alles nur...
Buffering.
22.36, zwei Minuten alt.
Ja, was soll ich machen? Ich kann es nochmal laden.
Einfach laufen lassen.
Geht wahrscheinlich nicht mit Apple.
Gibt es schon Livecrime.feel-Kaufwörter?
Steigen sie jetzt ein.
Nur hier die echten Turtles.
Das scheint mir echt ein gutes Businessmodell zu sein.
So, habt ihr noch Wünsche? Und sonst irgendwelche Sachen, die nicht in Hinweis sind? Hier liegen noch Sticker. Wir haben noch Sticker zu verschenken.
In Farbe und Bund. Und eckig und rund.
Ja.
Soße und Schaf, wir wissen das. Sonst nichts?
Nö, gut.
Dann schocken wir uns. Wir leiten mal das unvermeidliche Ende ein.
Das war früher aber länger.
Was?
Aber damals gab es auch noch Getränke.
Tim möchte heute nicht mehr über Max reden.
Früher gab es was? Getränke? Davon weiß ich nichts. Und Eis.
Dann sehen wir uns auf dem Kongress, oder?
Genau, dann sehen wir uns auf dem Kongress. Ihr hört uns irgendwann in den nächsten Wochen wieder, wenn wir wieder Freak Show machen. Das war die etwas trollige kleine Ausgabe hier. Ist das nicht toll?
Alle.
Danke.